hello i'm christopher hine and today
we're going to be talking about i forgot
what i was going to talk because i was
doing a new intro and i'm all messed up
but so today
today we're going to talk about
force angle in
the the uh ipitis so internal training
so we're looking at internal training um
one of the ways i like to break that up
is force angle force angle
could be used for an alignment right so
you could say an alignment is a force
angle and sometimes we'll also use force
angles that go perpendicular depending
on what we want to achieve so we're
talking about all the internal power
stuff you got to understand that
we're using both sides of it right so to
seem like we are more powerful sometimes
and also to make other people seem like
they are weaker right or you don't tell
them they're weak or you tell them that
they uh
that you're so strong you can resist
what they're doing right but uh it's
it's a it's a it's a way to change the
angle of the force to what they're doing
and it'll be deceptive for them and make
it really hard for them to make a lot of
force and then also you can improve the
angle to align the angle to make
yourself seem really strong so i know
this might sound confusing but i bet i
can clear it up right now i'll call josh
over here we'll go to work josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's talk about force
angle here okay um so uh force angle
might be a weird way to say this it's
just the way i say it um it's because it
incorporates a whole lot of different
weird stuff um
the way that force is applied and the
angle of that force and the angle of the
force that's resisting it is really
really important right so most of the
time the way our brains kind of think of
force is like this so if josh had his
hands up and he's pushing against me
that i push against josh's hands and so
his force is coming this way and my
force is coming that way and if josh is
stronger than me he'll push me over and
if i'm stronger than josh i push josh
over right so that's a real common way
to think of it i'm going to show it with
the stick because this stick to me makes
a makes a demonstration kind of fun okay
so
so if i was showing you that and i was
telling you that you know josh is going
to push me over and so his objective is
just to push me straight over like that
okay and i stand here like this and josh
goes to push me over okay now look he's
pushing pretty dang hard he's pushing
pretty hard and i'm on one foot and this
guy can't shove me over and why can't he
shove me over right well he can't shove
me over because while josh is pushing
this direction i'm pushing this
direction so the angle of the force that
i'm resisting him with isn't this way
right and if i'm on one foot and josh
pushes against me and i'm on one foot
this is what happens right he just
pushes me right over because i'm trying
i'm not stable as josh isn't so when
we're pushing this way he'll win but
when i push up like this josh's muscles
can't work two directions at one time
they either have to go this way or this
way so if i'm pushing against him this
way he will start to naturally even
without him knowing it start pushing
down right so he's going to start
pushing against me down now what that
does is actually roots me a little more
right so makes me a little more
connected to him to the ground and him a
little less connected to the ground so
that helps plus he cannot push as hard
this way because he's using his force
this way so he's kind of alternating his
force between down and out and down and
out and down and out so he feels about
half as strong as he normally would be
because he's using about half as much
force right so the time's alternating
between the two so while josh is pushing
directly into me this way i'm pushing up
against him and it makes me seem really
strong there was a woman
who went all around the world showing
these demonstrations back at the turn of
the century they called it the georgia
magnet there's actually several
different variations that showed these
different um kinds of demonstrations and
basically force angle was her number one
trick right she did a few other things
but force angles are number one and
force angle is really really deceptive
when you're doing that now force angle
can be uh used in another way and we use
it all the time we do the demonstration
so like if josh pushes into me like this
and he pushes into me right and i'm
really stable this is also force angle
now this is working in a different way
because what i'm doing is i'm allowing
that force to come in as straight into
my body as i can and be into the ground
right so the force angle of this uh joe
right now is really good it's really
strong so if i push down into it oh i
can't push it down because it's so
strong and essentially when i'm
resisting josh like that this is what
i'm doing i'm kind of lining this up now
if it would be perfect it would be
perfect if i could put my feet against
the wall and completely resist him i'd
be really strong or if josh stood on my
shoulders the force would go perfectly
down into the ground i'd be really
strong right i'd seem very very strong
but it's just the angle of the force i'm
allowing that force to come into a way
that i'm super super stable so that's
also a demonstration of force angle
if we were down here like this and i
showed this demonstration last time we
would go ahead and sit and says it with
me um so i showed this demonstration
last time on the leverage um if we're
like this and josh is pushing my hand
straight down to the ground so he's
trying to lock my hands down now if i
try to go directly against josh's force
up into them i can't do it but if i
change the force angle all of a sudden i
seem so friggin strong why because when
josh is pushing my hand this way instead
of pushing against his hand this way i'm
pulling my hand at a 90 degree angle to
his force so when he pushes down i pull
up like this now i can make my force
angle zero like we learned in the
leverage and i can drive into him and i
seem really really really strong the
reason is because i initially used force
angle to take away from the force that
he was using to lock me down to the
ground and then i aligned my force so i
go straight into them and i get the
better leverage like we talked about
last time and that's how that works
right
so there's tons and tons of ways to use
force angle just remember if someone's
trying to push at you pushing directly
back at them unless you're stronger
isn't a good idea but you can change the
angle of the force and when you do that
it'll be much harder for them to attack
you because their muscle only works in
one direction at a time so this is a
basic overview of force angle if it
seems a little fuzzy let me know and
i'll make some more videos last time
maya told me my leverage video i talked
too fast so maybe i'll come back in and
i'll make somewhere i talk a little
slower actually maybe i'll just write it
out and then you can read it at whatever
pace you would like to read it at
so that's force angle i'm going to come
in next time and talk to you a little
bit more about how this kind of stuff
works i'll i'll describe a few of the
other ones
i'm christopher hines joshua teehee my
solana mcdaniel is behind that camera
right there and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you